welcome to the presentation on figuring
out the slope let's get started so let's
say i have two points and as we learned
in previous presentations that all you
need to define a line is two points and
i think if you think about that that
makes sense
let's say we have two points and let me
write down the two points we're going to
have
let's say one point is
why isn't it writing
sometimes this thing acts a little
finicky let's see oh that's because i
was trying to write in black let's say
that one point is
negative one
comma three
so let's see where does where do we
graph that so this is zero zero we go
negative one this is negative one here
let me just write negative one negative
one and then we're gonna go three up
one two three because this is three
right here
so negative one comma three is going to
be right over there
okay so that's the first point and the
second point i'm gonna do in a different
color let's see the second point is
two comma one
so let's see where we would put that
well we'd count
one
two this is 2
comma 1 because this is 1 so the point
is going to be here right
so we've graphed our two points
and now the line that connects them
is going to look something like this and
i hope i can draw it well
no no no that's not a good line let me
try to do it better i'm just going to go
straight from this point
through that point
like that and i'm gonna do it and then
i'm just gonna try to continue the line
from here that might be the
best technique
something like that
that's close whoops microphone
as you can tell this is not a completely
professional operation
okay so let's look at that line so what
we want to do in this in this um
presentation is figure out the slope of
that line so let's let's write out a
couple of things that i think will help
you so there's a couple of ways to view
slope i think intuitively you know that
the slope is is the inclination of this
line and we can already see that this is
a downward sloping line because it comes
from the top left to the bottom right so
it's going to be a negative number the
slope so you know that immediately and
we'll have what we're going to do is
actually figure out how to figure out
the slope
so slope let me write this down slope
and oftentimes we'll use the variable m
for slope i have no idea why because m
clearly does not stand for slope
that is equal to there's a couple of
things you might hear change in y over
change in x
that triangle
which is pronounced delta just a greek
letter that means change so change in y
over change in x and that also is equal
to
rise
over run
and i'm going to explain what all this
means in a second so let's let's start
at one of these points let's start at
this green point negative one comma
three
so
how much do we have to rise and how much
do we have to run
to get to the second point two comma one
so let's do the rise first well we have
to go
we have to go minus 2
so that's the rise so the rise is equal
to
minus 2 right because we have to go down
2 to get to the same y as this yellow
point and then we have to run
right there we have to run plus three
so rise divided by run is equal to minus
two over three
well how would we do that if we didn't
have this nice graph here to actually
figure to draw on well we can do is we
can say
let's take this as a starting point
change in y
over change in x
is equal to we take the first y point
which is three
and we subtract the second y point which
is one
right you see that we just took three
minus one so that's the change in y
over and we take the first x point
negative one
minus the second x point
minus
two
so three minus one is two
and negative one minus two is equal to
minus three so same thing we got minus
two over three
now we could have done it the other way
and i'm i'm running out of space here
but we could have we could have made
this the first point if we made that the
first point then the change in y would
have been
let me see if i want to make it really
cluttered so to confuse you
change in y would be this y
1 minus 3 over change in x should be 2
minus minus one well one minus three is
minus two
and two minus negative one is three so
once again we got minus two thirds so it
doesn't matter which point we start with
as long as if we use the y in this
coordinate first then we have to use the
x in that coordinate first let's do some
more problems and actually i'm going to
try i'm going to do a couple just so you
see the algebra without even
graphing it first
so let's say i wanted to figure out the
slope between the points
five comma
two
and
three
comma five
well
let's let's take this as our starting
point so change in y
over change in x or rise over run
well change in y would be this five
five
minus this two
over
this three
minus this five
and that gets us three
this is a five over minus two
equals minus three halves
let's do another one
and this time i'm gonna try to make it
color color-coded so it'll be more
self-explanatory
so it's 1 comma 2 that's the first point
and then the second point is
is 4
comma 3.
so once again we say
slope
is equal to
change
in y
over change in x
we'll change in y we take the first y
let's start here and we'll call that y
y1 so that's
minus the second y which is that 2
and then all of that over
once again the first x
which is four
minus the second x which is that one
and this equals
three minus two
is one
and four minus one is three
so the slope in this example is one
third and we could have actually
switched it around we could have also we
could have done it the other way we
could have said
two
minus three
over
whoops 1 minus 4. in which case we've
gotten
negative 1 over negative 3 well that
just equals 1 3 again because the
negatives cancel out so i'll let you
think about why this and this come out
to the same thing but the important
thing to realize is if we use the 3
first if we use the 3 first for the y we
also have to use the 4 first for the x
that's a common mistake and also you
always have to be very careful with the
negative signs when you do these type of
problems
but i think that will give you at least
enough of a sense that you could start
the slope problems
the next module i'll actually show you
how to figure out the y-intercept
because as we said before the equation
of any line is y is equal to
mx plus b and i'm going to go into this
more detail where m is the slope so if
you know the slope of a line and you
know the y-intercept of a line you know
everything you need to know about the
line and you can actually write down the
equation of a line and figure out other
points that are on it so i'm going to do
that in future model modules i hope i
haven't confused you too much and and
try some of the slope modules you should
be able to do them and i hope you have
fun